よろしくお願いします
ダンマパダの法話でございますが
なんかかなり年取ってボケていますといろいろ間違いは犯しますので
もし説法中でいろいろ解説のところとか間違いがあったら
ご存知の方々はそれを皆様のために訂正してください
61番目 チャランチェーナーディガッチェイヤ セイヤンサディスマッタノ エーカチャリアンダッランカイラー ナッティバーレーサハーヤターもう一度言います
チャランチェーナーディガッチェイヤ セイヤンサディスマッタノ エーカチャリアンダッランカイラー ナッティバーレーサハーヤターティ
チャランというのは歩くという歩く人という意味で
この場合は一緒に歩む人ということで
いわゆる歩むと言ったら
一緒に散歩をするという意味じゃなくて
日本語で言えば一緒に散歩するだけのことかもしれませんだけど
一緒に歩むということは人生
生活するという意味なんですね
で 一生一緒に生活を共にするということで
それはパーリ語で単純に一緒に歩むということにしているんです
あまり誤解しないでください
そういう風に一緒に生活する人がナーディガッチェイヤ得られないならば
次に一緒に生活を共にするって誰と共にするのかというと
セイヤンサディスマッタノ
セイヤンというのは自分より精神的に優れている人々
サディスっていうのは自分と道徳的に精神的に同じ似ている人
ですから 上等か同格かということなんですね
そういう人と同居をするんだと
一緒に生活するんだと
そういう人がいないならばどうしますかと
いないということは誰が残るんですかね
ある人が一緒に生活してくて人を捜してるんですね
誰が探すのかというと
自分よりは道徳的に精神的に知恵で優れている人
目上の人 あるいはそれでなければ自分と同じレベルの人
見つからなかったということは
自分より精神的に 同格の反対はないんですね
精神的に自分より劣っているということになるんですね
見つからなかったということは
周りの人々は それならエーカチャリアン
一人で生活するんだと
ダッランカイラー 一人で生活すること
エーカチャリアンというのは
いわゆる全く 一人で何でもかんでもして
他の人々から離れて生活する
それがダッランカイラー
固くしましょう するべきであると
いわゆるものすごく覚悟を決めて
しっかり誰とも付き合わないと
一人で生活するんだと
誰とも混じらないんだということでね
これがダッランカイラー
固く行わなくちゃいけないんですね
理由は次に言うんです
なぜならばということ
ナッティバーレーサハーヤタ
バーレーというのは無知な人
衰えて劣った人と サハーヤタっていうのは仲良くすること
なってやりませんと そういう決まりがあって
劣っている人々とはごちゃごちゃ仲良くして混じっては生活しないんだよと
するべきではありませんという決まりがあって
それに合わせてこの今しま次に語っているんですね
まあそこであまり注は要りませんと思いますけどね
まあそういう部分分かりやすいと思います
あの 精神的にだけではなくて
道徳 精神 知識 何でもかんでも人間として必要というものはね
仏教ではお金だけはこの計算に入れてないんです
だから現代ね 我々の場合は順番違いますけど
昔は一番最初に道徳来て
それから知識が来て 俗世間ではね
人間にとっては第一大事なのは道徳であって
2番目に知識であると
3番目に財産というふうになっていたんですね
仏教になってくると やっぱり智慧が第一で
知識は 2番目で 道徳はね
次に知識は 3番目で それで仏教はあまり財産などなどというのはもうカットして関係ないということにしているんですね
現代人間ですから いろいろそうやって人間にとって大事なもの
宝物は何なのかというと
そのその社会でね いろいろ順番があると思いますけどね
ですから それは私は日本の社会で生きている人ではありません
だからあまりわかりませんだけど
話してみたこともないしね
で 私の部屋の中にいる誰もは何も言ってくれません
私しかいませんだからね
だからそういうところではなかなかわかりません
しかしね 世の中を見ると
それぞれね 人間にとって大事なものは何なのかというとね
まあそれぞれ決まりはあるみたいですけどね
世界政治学的に大事なものは何でしょうかと言えば
それだったら私は知ってますけどね
それ以外個人個人ではちょっとわかりませんだけど
当時昔インドでは一応インド俗世間では道徳
知識 財産ということになっていて
財産の中でもやっぱり 1に来るのは家族でね
それから家畜動物やら土地やらが次に来るんですね
で 土地よりも家畜動物を財産にしていたみたいですね
それは昔でね 今はもう鶏とかね
牛とか もうそれは土地よりも価値があるんだぞと言ったっても
何か病気にかかっちゃうと全部パーになっちゃいますけどね
[笑い] それは時代の流れでね
当時ではそんなに土地というのはそんなに大したものだと思っていなかったんですね
仏教になってくると 第一は智慧で
次に道徳でということになって
高い順で言えばね まあ次に知識ですね
勉強するの  それで終わりという
それ揃ってれば 人間にはもう何も必要でありませんと
そういう尺度で まあ誰と付き合えばよろしいかということを考えるんですよ
だから智慧がトップだから
そちらの反対は無知なんですよ
だから いくら財産があっても
いくら道徳があっても
いくら無茶学者で知識人であっても
無知だったらもう絶対付き合わないと
危ないと ということになるんです
[咳]